Pharaoh Ramesses II reigned
for almost 70 years
in the 13th century BCE.
He presided over a golden age
of Egyptian prosperity.
But was he a model leader,
or a shameless egomaniac
and master of propaganda?
Order! Order! Who do we have on the stand?
Ramesses II?
Ahem, I believe you mean
"The strong bull, protector of Egypt,
who subdues foreign lands;
rich in years, great in victories,
chosen by Ra— whose justice is powerful—
Ramesses, beloved of Amun."
But you may refer to him
as Ramesses the Great.
Ramesses, Ramesses—
I think I've heard of him.
"Let my people go!"
Yes, Your Honor, he was the infamously
stubborn pharaoh of Exodus,
who forced enslaved Hebrews
to build out his extravagant capital city
of Pi-Ramesses.
Objection, there's no
archaeological evidence
that Ramesses used forced labor
in his construction projects.
Egyptians relied on highly trained
artisans and craftsmen
to build their cities and monuments.
And menial labor,
like quarrying and moving stones,
was done by military soldiers
and foreign mercenaries—
all of whom were compensated
for their work.
So he's not the pharaoh from Exodus?
It's hard to say for certain.
According to some timelines,
Ramesses is the best candidate
for that particular pharaoh.
But there's no evidence of any Hebrew
population in Egypt during his reign,
and certainly no records of a revolution
or mass migration
like the one described in Exodus.
Is that really so surprising?
It's not like Ramesses kept records
of any other time he was defeated.
What do you mean?
Our "great" pharaoh here operated
one of the largest propaganda machines
in ancient history.
Almost all pharaohs relied on propaganda
to control their country,
and Ramesses had particularly
big sandals to fill.
His father, Seti I, led Egypt to a period
of great wealth and stability
that Ramesses worked hard to maintain.
Through propaganda, yes,
but also military glory.
More like military aggression.
By the end of Seti's reign,
he had established peace
with the neighboring Hittites
by guaranteeing Egyptian control
over a sought-after region called Kadesh.
But in the fifth year of his reign,
Ramesses broke those agreements.
It wasn't the most peaceful decision,
but Ramesses believed a military victory
would aid his efforts
to restore Egypt's reputation.
And he was right!
His victory over the Hittites
cemented Ramesses' persona
as a heroic pharaoh of old.
Yeah, except he didn't even win!
His supposed victory was
actually a stalemate
in which the pharaoh's arrogance
almost cost Egypt the entire war.
When two Hittite spies told Ramesses
the enemy had fled in fear,
he let his guard down,
allowing his men to be ambushed.
He played right into the Hittite's trap
and almost lost everything.
Yet the official story Ramesses
had chiseled across Egypt
cast himself as the battle's
greatest hero.
Military achievements were important
for legitimizing a pharaoh's power,
even if that meant a bit
of exaggeration.
A bit? You can't trust
anything this guy says!
If it wasn't for the Hittite's
conflicting record,
we'd still be buying Ramesses' propaganda.
I propose that this court cannot judge
any historical figure's legacy
by the stories they tell about themselves.
That seems reasonable to me.
Fair enough. How's this record then—
the first recorded peace treaty
in archaeological history
signed by Ramesses and the Hittites.
"Peace treaty" is pretty generous.
Ramesses begrudgingly agreed
to a mutual defense contract,
where Egyptians and Hittites would work
together if attacked by an external enemy.
And what's wrong with that?
This peaceful end to the conflict
marked the beginning
of Ramesses' prosperous reign—
a golden age of Egyptian power and wealth.
True, but we have no idea if this wealth
trickled down to everyday Egyptians
or just financed Ramesses' vain attempts
to achieve immortality through stone.
He spent his entire reign pouring
money into ego projects.
And one of the most famous,
Abu Simbel, wasn't even in Egypt!
Abu Simbel was in Nubia to showcase
Egypt's strength
and discourage a Nubian revolution.
Besides, pharaohs were expected to invest
in building projects for the gods.
Right, "for the gods,"
which Ramesses was not.
Pharaohs typically occupied a status
between gods and mortals,
but the location of Ramesses' statue
inside Abu Simbel
positions him as their supposed equal.
He even tore down existing temples
to reuse their bricks
in monuments to himself!
He tore down temples built by Akhenaten,
a pharaoh who'd attempted
to impose monotheism.
By destroying those temples,
Ramesses reinforced his commitment
to Egypt's traditional religion.
That doesn't account for why he frequently
erased other pharaohs' names on monuments
and replaced them with his own.
Hey, what the...?
Even pharaohs who had short reigns
had numerous statues made of themselves—
and Ramesses ruled
for almost seven decades.
Well, he definitely made
a lasting impression.
Let's face it, Your Honor, would we even
be talking about him today if he hadn't?
It's often said that history is written
by the winners,
but in this courtroom,
a winning record never guarantees
the outcome.